[Music]
foreign
you have so much love for for Los
Angeles and you have like I remember one
time and you just say these things it
just stuck with me so much but I
remember one time I think we're on like
some [__] press tour some [__]
and you were just like I mean we're in
like some Hotel you know we're like in
some hotel that I mean it's just like
you get tea in a [__] cup that like
it you know it's like a [__] car and
it's like you know Butler's wiping your
ass and [__] and you were like yeah I
was like so what are you gonna do next
you're just like I just got to get back
to the streets man figure out the [__]
is going on and I was like that's
exactly right man like it so like what
what did you find in La that you really
responded to be Beyond like the chaos
like what what kind of love did you
because I know you made like lifelong
relationships there and you found like a
family in the streets it was family it
was like
like
all the [__] that made me weird
or would make people uncomfortable about
me
in regular life became like a superpower
in the street right how so
um being able to hang being able to like
like like the streets are [__]
meritocracy right I don't care who you
say you are that's right they're gonna
break you down and show you who you are
real fast right
and
you know I'm hanging out with these
people it's funny like I'm 15 years old
and I'm in in this club called The Press
Club which doesn't exist anymore because
they put the uh Convention Center tore
it down and put the convention center
there like on Pico and and so like pico
like Pico and Olympic was like crazy
back in the day it was like 18th Street
controlled it and they ran prostitution
out of there and you go by the hotels
and you see all the homies and the
hyenas and everything and it was just
crazy
and so we'd go over there and drink go
to this place I'm 15 years old I'm
sitting in a strip club drinking beer
with the homies and it never occurred to
me like why is why am I being served at
15 in a [__] strip club you know or
I'd go to a neighborhood restaurant
and like the owners are like bending
over backwards to give you a [__]
drink right and I just it's like like I
was kind of like I never put it together
of like what's really happening here but
like you start to
go through these situations and it's
like oh it's the LAPD here comes a
[__] cops pajamas right
what happens if you [__] press the
cops
right so like you know normal civilian
world you don't do that or you know
right but on the streets it's like all
right two cops six of us every one of
these [__] will fight yeah some
dudes may have things that that are
worth fighting for that they don't want
the cops to have you know
how does this unfold now you know what's
the [__] psychology here you know and
then you see that moment where you see
like the fear and the cop's eyes and
it's like all right we got this got him
yeah yeah stomach [__] yeah you know
like and you start to
Savor these encounters you know and
and it was just like I was like
Crazy Dave crave
right that was like my name crave so
that's [__] crazy and and there's
always like the crazy guy and I guess
that was me like he always had that
reputation and and plus I was just in a
stupid [__] like
there's a lot going on you know like a
lot of weapons a lot of death a lot of
power
um
you know and I saw the transition from
like crack when when freebasing like
people would Freebase right
and it's like yeah the alcohol and the
[__] clip and the cotton swab and
that's how people were doing it right
for a minute and then I remember when
crack hit and totally different it was
like like oh [__] microwave baking soda
[__] rock it up
overnight it changed everything and one
of the first crack houses in La was like
on my block like on my [__] block
right and it's like
they would come through it was like like
my neighborhood was like rolling 20s
Bloods and and so like I had the Freeway
Rick connection all that [__] so there's
like kilos coming in my [__]
neighborhood and the key was like 14k
and everyone was just trying to get 14
Grand together because you could flip it
for 60. straight up yeah [__] it was
like
in the neighborhood started out like we
would play football with other
neighborhoods and and so like we came up
with like like like
marasa I used to hang out with Ms yeah
like but there were like Stoners back in
the day yeah like [__] long hair and
would wear like AC DC shirts and jeans
and Chucks like it was such a different
vibe but because I was close to
MacArthur Park where they all started
and I was like a house painter right so
I was always working with them and
working with people and in this world
and then the violence hit
and it just went like Cartoon Level
violence overnight
and the streets flipped from like it was
like the old heads and you know like
guys that played football in high school
and just like [__] like that just
suddenly like The Killers ran it right
so in my neighborhood it was some kid
who's like [__] 15 or something and
and suddenly he was the guy because he
was just killing everybody down for it
killing [__] everybody and and and
that's that violence piece and that
language of violence so it's like okay
so if you can just [__] kill people
and you don't have that conscious thing
going on oh you're gonna run the [__]
deck you know what's that look like and
for you for you at that point you you
had been around you'd seen all kinds of
events you've seen probably one of the
most violent acts you could with your
pops you've seen that but what about
your own sort of like bursting through
the bubble of perpetrating it yourself
and getting your hands dirty I mean what
was your relationship with that and was
that hard for you because I I we talk
about a lot on here just like how a lot
of that starts I know for me it started
a lot in like fear and shame like God
punks you you get your ass but you get
or something and then you're like you
sit there and like at night you're like
[__] I should have done this or [__] I
should have done that and then you'd do
it but then you start breaking through
that membrane you start perpetrating
yourself and then you kind of become the
monster a little bit and you become that
guy yeah did you have a similar Journey
do you remember like one of your first
sort of like real encounters with
violence that you had to perpetrate
yeah it was it's
it was a hash it was a hat like when I
was 17
got shot across the street from me my
house and like I don't know I was
feeling like a Good Samaritan or
something and I like [__] gave him
CPR you know and the dude like died I
was like 17. the dude [__] threw up
all over me and was throwing up blood
clots and [__] and I was like watch this
guy die man it's just like okay did you
know him no no he was from East L.A like
our issue was like like South Central
and East L.A were like [__] yeah like
and this is a different world then I was
like where are you from only from
nowhere [__] you boom like
I dated girls and he's still there too
you know they're like taking the bus
there as well like [__] a date of
this black girl in South Central like
Compton and I was taking like the
Vermont line at [__] midnight to go
hang out with her and stuff like I
didn't give a [__] like I went
everywhere
um
yeah it's
it's hard like like because it doesn't
make a lot of sense to me and I see
things and I'm like like for me it's
just memories right so like
walk into Vermont to go to work and like
there's this bar in my neighborhood Mr
X's bar which is like where all the
homies would hang out and in front of Mr
X's like it's [__] blood just all
over the sidewalk and blood clots and
[__] and just like nasty yellow [__]
clots and I'm like I gotta go to work
I'm just stepping over the blood like
nothing you know and that was like
normal that was like a normal thing like
like gunfire holy [__] every night
there's gunshots but not like [__] oh
someone shot a gun but like
boom boom boom fights like like yeah gun
fighting every night was it was normal
like it's crazy what becomes normal but
it's crazy yeah yeah yeah and and at
that point like when did you meet uh
Richard like when was it all in that in
that period no it's a little bit after
like high school world was a [__] show I
dropped out
um I was on L.A County Probation all
through high school so like I had to
take the bus down to Crenshaw on
Exposition and I'd like the gang lady po
so she was like all harsh on me and I
don't know why I had the gang lady po
because I was very innocent and didn't
do [__] and I was like
like
like only white boy in the [__] boss
RTD back then she was like 50 cents or
something you know I know it's just like
to be able to fit into that environment
and be comfortable and navigate it and
not get pressed like
yeah just to learn that energy can you
just like can you can you describe it a
little bit like can you uh
I mean I I I really feel like I
understand what you're saying and I and
and being in in those in those
situations
um it never really ends right like it's
not like it's like from place to place
it's not like you can be like oh I don't
need to deal with this anymore it's like
it's a constant it's a constant constant
navigation like um it's like an energy
thing either you belong or you don't
either you're comfortable or you're not
and like growing up
there's always like people of color
adopted me like like black families
vaccine families took me and fed me took
care of me you know so it's very
comfortable in those spaces and probably
not as comfortable with white folks no
which is crazy like like I remember boot
camp
um I was looking around look at all
these [__] white people like what the
hell is happening who are you well what
spaces are you comfortable being in you
know and then and then like I just
really a voice connected
with like heavy people like [__]
Killers like I'm moving through it
people have been through it what what
what why why the military what like how
did that come about
uh like my grandfather retired officer
other grandfather retired officer you
know one's Army women's Navy submarines
um I've always been drawn to that
um world you know through family stuff
but
like growing up in high school I'm like
maybe I graduate maybe I don't I didn't
but I'll join the military I'll get
[__] killed and I'll die young and
problem solved right like I never
thought I would live I never thought I
would live really past 18. so you know
like that was kind of my mindset
um
and then yeah I got in it and I did
really well and then I kind of got my
heart broken so
I was too idealistic I was looking for
the perfect home and I found it for a
second
um and it was like very different world
Cold War World very intense you know I
was on a nuclear submarine
um different culture back then you know
and
like there's a lot I won't say
uh but it was
[__] up like it put me in some
dilemmas you know and
you know I thought I was going to do it
my whole life ended up getting out
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody it's John
and Bam Bam the dog uh first on behalf
of both of us and everybody from the
real ones team I just want to sincerely
thank you guys for for tuning in the
folks that I bring on the show they're
family to me and uh being able to tell
their stories and bringing you into
their world is something I'm I'm just
super proud of and again grateful that
you guys tune in we've decided we want
to take things just a step further it's
a patreon community and basically what
that means is if you become part of this
community look I already board Bam Bam
if you want to become a part of this
community you're going to be able to
hear episodes early and all that ad free
and all that good stuff but there's all
this behind the scenes footage all this
stuff that we've shot that really brings
you into the folks that we've had on the
show really brings you into their world
live chats with me and the folks that I
bring on the show to talk about their
world talk about the issues that they're
dealing with but their triumphs and
their tragedies just go to patreon slash
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole wide
idea was something about building
bridges and and bringing people together
and bringing folks that often don't get
the mic and giving the mic to them so
the fact that you guys tuned in means
the world anyways again thank you uh be
good to each other out there rock and
roll